عن السودان
السودان بدم انا
يروا الجيش السوداني اليوم نفسه مرغما على
خوض حربه التي لم يخضها من قبل وقد كانت
ايسر وقد كانت اقل كلفه انها كما يقول حرب
الضروره التي انشاها وجود قوه عسكريه
ضاربه نمت في كنف الدوله حتى اصبحت خطرا
عليها فقوات الدعم السريع بقياده الفريق
محمد حمدان حميتي مثلت في نظري كثير من
العسكريين والمدنيين مهددا للدوله
السودانيه من جهه العسكريه ومن جهه
السياسه كذلك اذ لم يحدث في تاريخ الجيش
السوداني وتاريخ السودان منذ استقلاله ان
نشات قوه كثيره العتاد كثيره الجند تدير
شؤونها اسره تمويلا وتسليحا وتجريدا لها
في مهام مخارج السودان كما حدث للجيش
وللسودان خلال السنوات الاخيره من حكم
البشير ثم من بعد تحت قياده الفريق عبد
الف البرهان بصفته قائدا للجيش ورئيسا
لمجلس السياده
جرى التجارب الشعوب والحكم ان الدوله يكون
لها جيش واحد تحت قياده واحده السودان لم
يكن كذلك فقد باتت قوات الدعم السريع في
عين الجيش جمله نافره في العسكريه وفي
السياسه معه كانت بيانا صارخا فيما انتهت
اليه الدوله السودانيه من ضعف مؤسسي عسكري
وسياسي
المؤسسه الوحيده التي كانت تنمو في ظل
تراجع كل شيء في السودان هي قوات الدعم
السريع التي لم تستصحب اي مشروع سياسي او
فكري
تمت فكره واحده هي القوه نفسها وهي القوه
التي ستطلب السلطه ثمره لها فلطالما اتهم
حميتي بانهم تلا بفكره حيازه السلطه عن
طريق القوه فهي اداه ولا اداه له غيرها
والا ما حاجته الى انشاء قوه يزيد عدده
على مئه الف رجل تحت امراته وامراه اخيه
وقد استمر الاتهام له بانه كان ملحاحا في
طلب الحواضن كافلات القوه ففزع يطرد ابواب
القبائل والعشائر بابا يبذل لهم الاموال
والعطايا بسخاء ثم بدا له ان زعماء
القبائل والعشائر لا يستطيعون قطع الطريق
الى اخرها وليسوا بقادرين على بلوره طموحه
السياسي في لغه صالحه للتسويق الداخلي
والخارجي
وما زال يجد في طلب الانصار حتى انتهى الى
خيمه الاتفاق الايطالي مقدما نفسه الراعي
الرسمي للمشروع الديمقراطي في السودان
ولعل وهما او حقيقه استقرت لدى بعض قطاعات
القوى المدنيه الحديثه فحواها لما لا يكون
حميدتي حمايته ايضا في نسخه محدثه من
تجربته مع عمر البشير
وكان طبيعيا ان تقع الحرب التي لم يكن
منها بد بعد ان بلغت التناقضات العسكريه
والسياسيه نهاياتها العدميه ويقول الجيش
انه يحارب قياده قوه عسكريه كانت حتى امس
توصف بانها من القوى النظاميه في الدوله
ويحتل قائدها موقع نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
وبهذا المعنى فان الخطاب المؤسس لشرعيه
واخلاقيه الحرب من وجهه نظر الجيش هي انه
يقاتل قوه منه تمردت عليه وهذا التوصيف
بالكاد يترك مساحه لمتدخل بالحسنى او
بغيرها تاركا مصير السودان بين خيارين اما
انتصار الجيش انتصارا ساحقا تحل به كل
التناقضات العسكريه التي تسببت دعم السريع
بارتباطاته الخارجيه في وجودها واما ان
تنتصر قوات الدعم السريع على الجيش فينهد
اهم ركن في الدوله واخ مؤسسه لازمه لامن
الاوطان وبقائها هل تم خيار ثالث انه خيار
الحوار والدخول في مفاوضات برعايه اقليميه
او دوليه ثلاثيه او رباعيه او خماسيه او
اكثر من ذلك لكن التجارب البعثات الدوليه
والمبعوثين والرعاه على كثرتهم ما اسعف
التجاربهم في جلب السلام الى اليمن ولا
الى ليبيا ولا الى سوريا او الصومال ولا
غيرها من الدول في اثيوبيا مثلا رفض ابي
احمد رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي في حربه ضد
المتمردين من التقراي رفضت تدخل الاتحاد
الافريقي في الشان الاثيوبي قال لا وفي
عاصمه بلاده اديس ابابا تخفق اعلام
الاتحاد الافريقي وبالطبع لم يتجرا احد
على دعوه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى
الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات لحل الصراع
بينه وبين الرئيس
المشكك في شرعيه فوز بايدن وفي رئاسته
ولذلك قد تبدو خشيه السودانيين في محلها
من فكره التدخل الوسطاء الدوليين لحل صراع
داخلي يجب ان يحل بوسائله
فالوسطاء الدوليون والاقليبيون ليس في
سجلهم تحقيق سلام في بلد ما ولا يضل بهم
ذلك خاصه اذا كان ذلك البلد هو السودان
حيث تتقاطعوا مصالح ومطامع الداخلين في
شؤونه عبر اختراقات في عسكريته وفي سياسته
وتفاوض الطرفين في السودان اذا تم لن يكون
في احسن احواله غير ترحيل للازمه الى
المستقبل الى حرب اخرى غير هذه